and q music and q nathan
happy founders day rutherford falls
you know our fair town wasn't always
going to be called rutherford falls
that's right old lawrence changed his
mind six times at one point he was dead
set on naming it after his brother horus
you say that out loud it sounds like
whoresville
needless to say they moved on from that
one pretty quick i guess what i'm trying
to say is
changing one's mind is distinctly
rutherfordian
and that's why i've changed my mind and
i've come to the conclusion
that it's the right thing to do to move
big larry yeah nope it's okay don't
freak out don't freak out no it's
actually kind of exciting because the
new location
is pretty cool good for you nathan can
we focus on the problems that are
actually important
well big larry's important more
important than the opioid crisis
yeah apples and oranges carla we should
refurbish him
he looks old and sad okay folks this is
not a q
a uh but all right bunny let's wrap it
up support refurbishing not re-sculpting
through that we should get a new statue
that thing's like a billion years old
what about like jenna marbles or my dog
she's got like 2
000 followers on instagram people the
moving of big larry is
on the table not replacing him are you
kidding me he's the heart and soul of
this town
i have something to say oh no bonnie in
1951
a woman named juanita cordova went into
labor on her way to albany we've had
this argument bonnie she couldn't wait
and gave birth to a daughter in
rutherford falls that little girl would
become
tv superstar linda carter wonder woman
was born in our town
okay yes a woman named linda carter was
born in our town there is absolutely no
evidence that it was the
linda carter who went on to tv stardom
we are not building a statue
of wonder woman in our town deirdre
backman
i respect the voices of my constituents
let's chase this momentum in a hundred
years who's gonna care about big larry i
don't care about him right now
is that right that statue sucks
shut up shut your stupid pie holes just
laugh yeah cause you don't get it you're
not
getting it okay a bunch of years ago
lawrence rutherford
wrote and signed a legally binding
agreement with the minnesota
that's why this town exists that's why
all of you exist okay lawrence
rutherford is our forefather
he's our adam and eve our our tigris and
euphrates
and that statue which sits on my
family's land
commemorates all that he gave us and if
you don't get that well you're just an
ungrateful boob
you know what i'll change my mind again
big larry's gonna stay right where he is
nope not gonna budge not only that but
i'm gonna double down on my efforts to
make sure each and every one of you
understands exactly how important he is
and why it's so important
that he's there and if you disagree you
can burn in hell
yeah just burn right up you gotta go get
your boy
okay no but i'm not done telling these
people why they're wrong and stupid okay
all right okay but there's you're gonna
hear more about this
[Music]
you